[Music]
what's your name uh natalie hey natalie
what's on your mind so um earlier you
alluded to the dangers of polarization
of ideologies like um
more specific like not being able to sit
with conflict because without conflict
without being able to sit in conflict in
a safe space and respect respectful
space
leads to war
and
with like the ever-changing times and
things such as like council culture
being so prominent i just wanted to know
what your thoughts were on cancel
culture and how to
navigate those spaces when
feelings are very high yeah
so so i don't i think cancer culture is
a bit overblown right i mean the only
people who truly get cancelled are
usually people who do some pretty
hideous things i'm not so sure about
that so that's good that's good to
scream it right here that's good that's
that's good
he would have disagreed with whatever i
said yeah
uh but and we'll get to that in a second
because i do want to talk about cancer
culture i think there there may be some
elements there but yeah we might
disagree on this but here's what i will
tell you we were just in washington dc
on january 6th
we had a tour stop there was an
insurrection of love
and um
there were four of us on stage it was me
and ryan and our friend tk coleman
and a guy named ken coleman who you've
probably heard on the podcast as well
and i realized
i didn't get to say this on stage there
so we might as well talk about it here
all four of us voted differently in the
last election
and
that's never even come up between us
right
now the underlying things not our
beliefs but our values
those things come up all the time and
yeah maybe ken has a different path to
get to the same values but we end up
there anyway and so i think putting
yourself in those
spaces not to disagree not to agree
either i don't want to just be like oh
yes yes that's right now
because then you don't feel good you
don't feel authentic right
but what if i just want to hear you
what if i want to hear your point of
view
because it
whether or not it sways me it gives me
another perspective from which i can
live my life
now tell me about cancer culture oh yeah
well here's a couple of things i'd love
to this is a great question i mean it's
on a lot of our minds um
you know one of the things that disturbs
us about people who think differently to
us
is not so much that they
that they are other to us but they
expose our own otherness to ourselves
and what i mean by that is if if you
believe something different to me i
either want to consume you would you
like if you eat something it becomes
part of your body so i want to make you
into my social body if i can't do that i
want to vomit you out i want to get rid
of you put you out of the community
just like a child put something in in
her mouth and if she can't swallow it
spits it out or
we could tolerate each other like let's
not talk let's just kind of like work
and whatever but don't tell me your
strange ideas or hey beneath all of our
differences we all you know are are are
taking from the same stream i think
that's the worst one right because in in
all four of these in the first three i'm
right and you're wrong and then the
fourth hey we're both right
what's most interesting to me about the
other
is that i think you're strange monsters
and weird and then i see myself through
your eyes and i'm like i'm a bit strange
monstrous and weird right like i thought
that the way i did things was completely
normal but oh now i see myself through
your eyes i'm decent or destabilized
that's a bit that's a bit weird
and that's a powerful experience so
sometimes i imagine what would it be
like to have a debate you're saying
democrat i'm republican and we instead
of having a debate where
you're the democrat i'm trying to make
you republican
you're trying to make me democrat i'm
saying to you listen i have no idea why
you're a democrat i don't understand
that i don't understand why you're not
on my side help me see myself what am i
missing and then you're the same you're
never going to make me into a republican
but i must be missing something because
i think you're nuts what do you what
what is it that you see in me that's a
bit weird and then we become instruments
of each other's further conversion now
one other thing i wanted to say about
this is a great example i'm not a i'm an
apocalypticist right an apocalypticist
not a progressive i'm apocalyptosis um a
progressive person often knows where
they're going and where things are
headed right and so if you love someone
who thinks differently from you it's
kind of a bit of a patronizing love
because you know where things are going
and you just kind of are nice to them
but you kind of know where it's going an
apocalypticist and apocalypse means the
incoming of something you cannot know
right it's the income it's the end of
one world in the beginning of another so
an apocalypticist you go in and you
don't know what the future looks like
all you know
is that you have to engage in the
conflict so in the good friday agreement
the the conflict the troubles ended
because all sides were going like
we need to get into a room together and
all sides had to go we don't know what
it's going to look like on the other
side of this we just need to engage in
the conflict and through this engaging
in the conflict the good friday
agreement or the good friday accord was
signed that was apocalyptic that nobody
could have imagined that involved the
desponding of the entire police force it
involved the changing of uh they
involved lots of crazy things you would
find hardly imagine um
and
uh oh yeah and just one example
concretely if you're in a relationship
right and you've been going out for a
long time and there's all of these
underlying issues and you're not talking
about them right and you know there's an
affair and someone's overworking and the
symptoms are coming out and the child
wetting the bed or an anorexia or in
heart disease the symptoms are there but
nobody's talking about them right this a
symptom by the way is the truth that you
cannot speak finds a way to speak right
so you know whether it's stomach issues
or fatigue or whatever a symptom uh
which in french sounds like santom which
sounds like huliman which sounds like
prophet which tells you the truth your
symptoms tell you the truth of your life
that you cannot face yourself so the
anorexia whatever tells the truth anyway
you go to an analyst
now the analyst technically says doesn't
say i know where your relationship is
going to go
they go i don't know and you don't know
maybe you are going to talk about stuff
and you're going to end up together
or maybe you're going to end up not
together or maybe you're going to split
up with the type of relationship you
have but stay together which is the most
radical one often people break up with
the person but never with the type of
relationship they have with people so
they end up having the same relationship
with lots of different people when the
more radical thing is to break up with
the type of relationship you have unless
maybe stay with the person anyway the
point is you don't know what's going to
happen all you know is if you raise the
conflict to the surface and you all
speak it light and you all put it out
something's going to happen you can't
stay the same a new future is going to
arise a post-apocalyptic event is going
to happen and that is kind of what i
hope for is that we all kind of are a
little bit more apocalyptic in our
outlook and go
all i know is that engaging in the
conflict is important and uh and and if
we do that something novel will arise
novelty is important i don't know what's
going on but something's going to arise
it's novel and new
i i do want to talk about cancer culture
i think i whatever question you ask me
i'll just say what i want to say and
that's what i said you know
that's a great technique you just answer
whatever question you wish
i'm like in the middle uh between you
and peter because when it comes to
cancer culture i i have seen people get
canceled where i'm like you're the best
but then other people i'm like oh that's
a shanda like that so i mean can we
maybe let me get concrete with it
because yeah harvey weinstein canceling
but he's not going to be in cancer he's
been put in prison so like if that's
what we're talking about great
yeah um the the justice system canceled
him right yes but who were we talking
about who has been cancelled unjustly
um and what have they been canceled from
and the reason i'm asking this is
because quite often what we see is that
you have a youtube creator who has been
demonetized and it's like
okay so what like
first off yay now you can't run [ __ ]
ads on your channel yeah right but but
also like so what you expect that some
major corporation they're supposed to
curate advertisements on your behalf and
because you said some things that were
incendiary that they didn't like of
course if a corporation doesn't like you
they're not going to support you right
and so i think quite often
maybe the way that i would say it is
this cancel culture stuff is overblown
by people with megaphones who say oh i'm
i'm terrified of being canceled well
you're not owed anything by these major
corporations and if you want to be in
bed with these gigantic major
multinational corporations you got to
play by their rules if you don't then
well then you can do what ryan and i do
we're not beholden to anyone and because
we're not beholden to anyone i don't
have to watch what i say i don't have to
worry about i mean we don't even
monetize our youtube channel because i
don't want to have to worry about that
so the answer is uh yeah if you don't
like cancel calls culture just don't be
cancelable
don't don't put yourself in a position
where you can be cancelled don't don't
partner with anyone who can cancel yeah
how do you feel about cancer culture
what brings us up for you um i was more
like focusing on the underlying well
what i think are the underlying issues
where if
if we are so quick to cancel and i don't
have anyone in mind
but if we are so quick to cancel someone
that we kind of break that
like
there's no bridge between being able to
have a conversation yeah and
understanding not that we have to agree
at all but
just having that safe space to be able
to discuss so that we can learn and kind
of meet half ways and if we just cancel
immediately we kind of break that tie
and are not are not able to rebuild that
connection yeah wherever that may lead
well you know the the biggest problem
like i see with cancer culture is you
know we we put our politicians and we
put uh ceos and whoever else movie stars
we put them on this pedestal
like they're supposed to have this level
of morality
that
that uh that gets them to deserve to be
on this pedestal
and the fact is is like none of us are
really on a pedestal very few of us
there might be some exceptions you know
uh jesus christ the buddha like there
might there are some exceptions that
maybe you can put on these pedestals but
the problem is the
99.99 of us cannot put ourselves on
pedestals so i think that's probably
like problem number one the second thing
is when we
when we participate in cancer culture
and you know we become part of the crowd
and you know we we feel good when we see
someone get canceled what we're doing is
is we are really eliminating the
opportunity for someone to like grow
and to learn from like past mistakes
that they've done now there are certain
mistakes that you're going to go to
prison for doesn't matter how long ago
you did them but you know but
unfortunately you find some off-colored
joke 10 years ago on twitter and now
we're going to cancel that person i
would much rather
have uh someone
in a in a position of power that screwed
up that was a [ __ ] and then totally
learned how to not be a [ __ ] anymore
like that i respect way more
than someone who's up on a pedestal so i
mean
that's that's
that's one of the major things um yeah
problems i have with the cancer quality
pete
i don't know man i think that person who
tells that 10 year old joke or whatever
i don't think we actually end up
canceling them though like i i don't
think that's really a thing that we're
there are some people who pretend to be
outraged so maybe the real problem is
this sort of recreational outrage and
now that uh i can pretend that i'm upset
about everything here's the truth no one
has the power to upset you
no one
only you have the power to upset you
right
and so
that is true and and yet we think oh
this person really offended me they
really upset me and therefore i also
need to react to it i need to do
something about if that's what we're
talking about with with canceling then
yeah i totally get it the mobs of people
who get really really easily upset
sure that's that's one thing
but um they if someone gets upset at me
i don't have to be upset back did you
enjoy this standalone patreon highlight
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
slash the minimalists or click the link
in the description your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel one
hundred percent advertisement free